So again,
thank you for taking the risk to come
to a talk where there was a mysterious
word in the title. I will explain
it over the course of this talk. Um,
so the first place I want to
start is with this person. Um,
I've already given a clue,
but does anyone know who this is?
Yeah,
it is. It is eight 11 list. Um, and the
reason I bring her up on screen, um,
is uh, not because of her stature. Um,
and not because she was the world's
first computer programmer working with
Charles Babbage.
Um,
but because it was in her
memoirs of working with Babbage,
um, that she included this quote. Um,
Babbage of course, did both
the differential engine
and the analytical engine.
And in her memoir she put the sentence,
the analytical engine has no
pretentions to originate anything.
It can do whatever we know
how to order it to do.
I'm Alan turning in his
understated,
a seminal paper computing machinery
and intelligence called this lady, uh,
level laces.
Objection.
Okay.
This caught my eye when I read
this, partially because, um,
she was objecting against something
that nobody had objected to yet.
They didn't have time.
The computer didn't exist.
So why was she sort of forestalling an
argument here? Why was she saying no,
it's cool. Computers
can't do anything. Um,
I looked further back,
obviously then Lovelace and Babbage and
found the answers probably in mythology,
right all the way back. And I know this
is a screen grab from the Disney version.
Um, but the original good to version of
the sorcerer's apprentice was a piece of
mythology that said, hey, look,
tech can go way out of control.
And in fact,
in that poem,
it was only the presence of the sourcer
that saved the world from destruction,
from tiny brooms.
Sorry.
Another myth comes from
the Golem of Prague.
If you're not familiar with this,
this was a, a creature made of clay.
It had a pretty cool little thing where
you put a gif on its forehead to bring
it to life. Um, but then after that,
this one doesn't have a mouth. Um,
but anything that you wrote as an
instruction and put it in its mouth,
it would just follow mindlessly
as best as it could. Right?
And it was a story of
sort of Hubris and terror.
Watch the machine go crazy with this
instruction. I'm going, of course,
we still tell terrifying tales of machines
that go awry for their instructions
and, and rec human damage on
their, uh, on their path. Right?
That's a how from 2001,
a space odyssey.
So there are lots of
places across myth in past,
before Lovelace's time and certainly
after where we're telling ourselves this,
these tales of the technology is
terrifying and should not take initiative.
Um,
and I'm going to
take that question as we move forward,
um, partially as a narrative construct,
but it's also the question that drove
some patterns that I had identified
probably about an starting
about 10 years ago, but, uh,
really started thinking about it pretty
hard about five years ago and that was a
pattern that I saw in the world.
So does anyone know what
the object on the left is?
It's pretty easy to gimme right?
This is to encourage you to talk. Um,
it's a DSLR camera. In fact,
that's the model that I have.
Does anyone recognize the object on the
right? It looks like a tile. In fact,
it's creepily like a tile,
but it's not a tile. Yes,
that is the get narrative camera. Um,
and if you're not familiar with it,
the way it works is you,
you leave it plugged up and plugged in
overnight so it has a battery charge and
then you unplug it.
As long as that Lens sees light,
it takes a picture every 30 seconds
of whatever's in front of it.
Then you come home at the end of the day,
the camera's taken about three,
5,000 photos. You plug it in
and it does for cool things.
The first is that automatically
uploads all those photos to a server.
The second thing is it uses some smart
algorithms to divide your day into scenes.
Here's when you were at breakfast,
here's when you were at lunch.
Here's when you were
listening to Chris Talk.
Third thing it does is it uses some
algorithms to detect what the best photo
from that set is based on
things like level of clarity,
contrast,
that sort of thing.
And the last thing it does is it uploads
those photos to a phone for you to say,
what do you want me to do with these? And
the APP is pretty clever. You can say,
Oh yes, I love that one, post that
one to social media. Or you can say,
I disagree with you on this one.
Show me all of the images and let
you rifle through. And by the way,
learn for next time what
I likened my images.
You can tag folks and you can
delete it. You can say, wow,
don't share any of these things.
Um,
and so that's what the
[inaudible] narrative camera does.
It's part of a category of cameras
called the life blogging camera.
And for my money, what makes us really
interesting is that they're both cameras,
but the one on the right is a
camera without a photographer.
Does anyone know what
the thing on the left is?
Thanks
Dyson brand vacuum cleaner.
And the thing in the right,
I probably don't have to
explain it's a Roomba. Right?
And similarly to the get narrative camera,
we have two objects that ostensibly
do the same thing for their users,
but the one in the left requires you
to grab it with your hand. In fact,
that's the only purpose that handles
serves. Right. And to use it,
you step on a switch to unlock it and
you step on a second switch in order to
turn it on and then you push the
vacuum around the house. Meanwhile,
this thing does the same thing,
but there's no handle,
there's no real step free
to step on to unlock it. Um,
there is something where
you can turn it on manually.
That's what that big button.
Yes.
But the important thing here is that
it's a vacuum without a vacuum or pardon?
That would be clever. Or if I was
working in another language than English,
but right. There's no human
whose job it is to vacuum there.
It's not quite automatic because if
I spill cocoa on my, on my floor,
I can grab that thing,
put it nearby and say clean here and
it'll focus on that spot for a little bit.
Room has recently been blasted
this week in the news, um,
for some of their privacy violations.
But let's bypass that for now.
I just want to talk about the functions
and the thing on the left is what,
it's a car, right? And the thing
on the right is that your car,
at least the current model
that I'm aware of, um,
and it's a similar in that in that same
pattern it's a car but without a driver,
right? And when you look at
all three of those things,
they are emblematic of a larger
pattern that I was seeing in my life.
I had a, um, automatic cat
feeder, so when I traveled,
my cat wouldn't starve or I didn't have
to ask a friend to come over. Um, and,
and at the time that I began thinking
of these ideas really deeply,
I was working in a Robo investor.
And so this was something that you
would say how much money you had,
how much money you would give each month,
and what your financial goals
were from that point forward.
The investor would manage your portfolio.
And the thing when thinking
about these patterns,
what they all sort of shared was that they
all did things on their users' behalf,
but they weren't quite automated.
But to get narrowed a camera,
you can actually tap it in order to take
a photo or take a video with the Roomba,
you can pick it up and force
it to vacuum somewhere.
That wasn't in its current plan,
I'm presuming I've never ridden in one,
but that you can stop
the Google car and say,
I've got a p or let's take a food break
or I want to go see what that is thing
over there.
So they're not quite automated.
And when I tried to dig deep and to sort
of the epistomological definition, um,
it seemed to me that the major difference
was that you grant these things agency
to act on your behalf.
So for my money,
this pattern was rightly
called agent tive technology.
I didn't make up that word, but I rescued
that word from obscurity. I think, uh,
before I published it, the only place
it was used, it was in linguistics,
but that's what I'm calling it.
This weird space in between
automation and assistance.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about that later.
But that's the pattern I had identified.
Now these are all first world problems,
admittedly,
but they're super easy to understand
and that's why I go to these as examples
first and quite commonly in the book.
But I really wanted to push
the idea and say, okay,
are there some third world problems or
other world problems that this technology
can be applied to review
them kind of quickly.
And the upper left hand
corner is ShotSpotter.
If you're not familiar with this tech,
what this service does is it will work
with a precinct and the United States in
order to sprinkle microphones all over
a neighborhood. There's microphones, uh,
aren't particularly great,
but they do have fantastically accurate
clocks and they're connected to the
network and they're trained
to listen for gunfire.
The men of Nehemiah hear gunfire.
They report the exact moment they heard
it back to a server and of course you
can triangulate it and the cool thing is
the accuracy of that is down to a meter
and doing an interview with
ShotSpotter for this book. Uh,
they love to tell a tale of one pair
of officers who were able to arrive in
winter
so quick.
They were able to respond so
quickly to the gunshots that uh,
even though there was snow in the ground
and they were worried they wouldn't be
able to find the shell,
they did find it by the smoking
hole that it left in the snow.
Pretty cool. Right in the upper
right hand corner is Volvo.
It can really with their self
breaking trucks in the grill,
they have a series of sensors that not
only track motion but actually a extended
that motion.
And if the vector of any object in motion
intersects with the car and the driver
is not breaking it,
they will break it.
It's going to save a ton of lives even
before we have self driving trucks.
That's a human augmentation
in the lower left is a swarm
robot called Prospero, uh,
designed and prototyped in Australia.
And with these little robots,
you can actually set some seed in here,
show it a map,
tell it what kind of seeds they are and
the swarm can go out and plant crops, um,
accurately and quickly
in a matter of moments.
Some major issues with what do we do
with the workers who used to do that sort
of thing. But all of this technology
has that question underneath it.
The nice thing about Prospero is that
it is not only faster but also safer.
So dangerous terrain.
The robots, you know,
they can handle it fine and we don't mind
if a robot breaks it's little league.
And the lower right hand corner
is a service called scare crow.
This is a drone that is trained to hover
high above endangered herds and watch
for humans that are approaching.
And if it doesn't know those humans,
it will drop down in
between the herd and humans.
And the wasp like buzzing will scare
the herd in the opposite direction.
Now I made that last one up.
It's a lie,
but the reason I made it up is I thought
of a problem in the world that bugged
me, animal rights. Um, and I tried to
apply this kind of thinking, this pattern,
this template to the problem and I was
able to come up with something fairly
quickly and fairly compelling.
In fact,
I was giving this talk in Delft in the
Netherlands prelate fairly recently and
one of the audience members raised his
hand and say, Oh yeah, we're a Dutch.
People are already building that.
So it's a viable idea,
at least for the Dutch
to seem to think so. Um,
but all of these are
sort of to illustrate,
even though they're a
little more complicated,
a little more nuanced that
the pattern of agency,
it doesn't just apply to first world
problems even though those are easier to
understand.
So one assert that yes,
I think it's as big as we can think.
Put that part down.
Pattern established.
I'm going to talk to you
about five reasons why you
think this pattern is nifty.
The first is that it's new,
but you can hear in my voice and you
should be able to see on the slide that
there are air quotes around the word new.
The reason why is because
that image in the background,
does anyone recognize what that is?
Yeah.
Yes. A particular machine
within the cockpit autopilot.
Anyone want to take a stab at when the
first autopilot was demonstrated to
Chicago world's fair,
1914 103 years ago.
Now, of course it was
electromechanical at the time.
It took a lot of engineering effort, a
lot of money in order to make it. Um,
but that's a piece of
agent tiff technology.
You granted agency to fly the plane and
it doesn't just do it automatically.
We still have pilots on those planes,
even with our modern autopilot's.
But let's put that down between that
and the thermostat that you'll see in
chapter one of the book.
Um, it's kind of new.
There are lots of precedents
in the world ahead of this,
but the reason I say that it's new that
public API Apis for neuro artificial
intelligence have become available
within the past five years.
IBM's yours open Ai's right?
The
public understanding and appreciation
of these services are on the rise.
So we have a marketplace that
will sort of accept them.
We don't have to train
them on this sort of thing.
We have a lot of centers that are an
actuators that are available to us as
designers and makers in order
to make these things happen.
I have 32 examples in the book.
Here's a question mark there.
I don't remember the exact
number. Um, but all of them,
except for the autopilot or within
the past five years, so it is new.
I believe that this is a way of
thinking that's ahead of a curve.
So new, pretty cool. Second
reason is that it is different.
If you've ever studied
interaction design like I did,
we talk about things like affordances
and mapping and all those things and the
canonical example for that as a hammer.
How does a human know how to
use that hammer? Well, they
look at it and they say,
oh well this looks like it fits a hand
and as long as I'm going to grab it at
the end, that looks hard. So it should be
able to hit something and drive a nail.
Those affordances, those mappings,
those systems states, uh,
are all belonged to
something like a hammer.
But that doesn't apply when you're
talking about an agent of model. Right?
You don't need an affordance for the
Roomba because I don't have to grab the
handle.
Okay.
I don't need mapping when it comes to the,
I'm not going to say Google car cause
course you need mapping for a car.
I don't need mapping when it
comes to my cat feeder. Right.
I just need good controls to set the
thing up and some kind of feedback
mechanisms to let me know that yes,
my cat is being fed. So for my money,
if the hammer is not the right model
for an agent of technology, what is,
and I think you can go turn to a
butler or a valid as a better model.
You would tell this person what your
goals were and what your preferences were
and from that point forward it would
manage as best as it could to those goals
and preferences. It would come to
you and there was a problem, hey,
the larder is empty or in case of a of
a valid, I don't have any clean clothes.
Something's gone wrong here and you
would help it and you can even tweak it
saying,
wow,
I appreciate your bringing me that tie
but I never want to see it again. It's,
it's hideous and ugly.
To illustrate this notion that the,
the, the model must be different. Um,
I built a model of interaction design.
If you studied this should
be pretty familiar, right?
Humans sees the state of the system. They
think that's not quite the right state.
What can I do next?
Judging the affordances of the system and
they do something to the system, right?
They press a button way of a hand speak
of something and then if that's the red
human part,
the blue is the familiar computer part.
Computer takes that input goes through
some sort of algorithm and result in an
output. This we know is a
oversimplified model of human cognition,
but it's a very useful over simplified
model of human cognition and interaction
design.
But when we compare that to a
model for agents give technology,
it gets different. So right. If the, if
the computer of course still down here,
but if there's a computer running
the system with a human, not gone,
but just on the outside of the system,
peaking in occasionally making requests,
tweaking.
Then we run into a whole lot of different
use cases and that's what this map is.
It's in the book that you have a,
it's in piecemeal throughout section too,
but it's in its whole version in
the very back on the appendix,
but you can see here the unique use
cases for this involve a lot of setup.
How do you give that agent of technology
your goals and your preferences towards
getting to those goals?
Oh,
I want my son to go to
college when he is of age.
Is it going to be a state school or is
it going to be really expensive school?
Right?
This preferences,
do I want investments to go to vice
funds are specifically not to go to vice
funds.
All the sorts of things that one might
think about in the setup of like a Robo
investor, use cases for seeing
or of course monitoring.
How do I build trust that this thing is
going to do what I needed to do and it's
in charge of something as important as my
money? How do I know that it's working?
How do I know when it's running
out of things like resources,
right?
So there are some unique use cases for
seeing and then there's doing right?
Pausing and restarting a,
one of the great things from the research
that we did for the Robo investors,
we wound up talking to a guy and we said,
okay,
if you had $1 million and you wanted
to give it to the Robo investor,
how would you that million
up? And he said, well,
I give the Robo investor probably
900,000 but I keep 100,000 for myself.
And we said, why? He said, I'm going to
see if I can beat it. And we were like,
this is an algorithm that looks at the
entirety of the market. He was like, yeah,
but I'm sure I have some
instinct that it does it right.
So that need to play alongside
was sort of illustrated. Um,
because we're talking about
narrow artificial intelligence
and we'll get to that
in a little bit. Um, it's
going to get some things wrong.
So the user needs tools in
order to tune it's black lists,
it's white lists,
it's a play.
And then of course for problems,
there's a hand off and
take back problem or the A,
and I runs into something
that it can't cope with. Um,
and we need elegant ways to pass back
and control back and forth. And lastly,
since almost all agents are persistent,
trained to watch some data stream for a
trigger and then execute their behaviors,
um,
we get into a problem with disengagement.
How do we know when the
agent is no longer necessary?
In the case of an invest a Robo
investor, it's significant. If I die,
that money just doesn't
stay with the Robo investor.
It needs to go to somebody that I need.
So that disengagement
becomes really important.
Not so much with the Roomba but
certainly in other circumstances.
So this model,
these unique use cases are sort of
underscoring what I say when I say, Hey,
this is new and unique.
Okay.
Number three,
we have been studying usercenteredness
for a long time and part of what we are
always doing as we apply designed towards
the problems at hand is we try and
maximize the user value and minimize the
amount of work that they have to do to
get there.
And I can't imagine a better equation
then nearly zero input for maximum user
value.
Right?
For familiar with pine and Gilmore in
1999 they published a book called the
experience economy and they categorize
the types of products that can be pushed
to market in one of four ways.
The first is of a commodity,
barely differentiated,
cheapest dirt traded on the market.
And if you wanted a cup of coffee and that
was their example. So I'm using it to,
you would go and go to a wholesaler,
bring a bag with you and a
scoop and scoop that stuff and,
and you'd pay less than a
cent for that bag of beans.
Commodities are really cheap because
they require the user to do a ton of work
and next level up is called a product
where the company says, you know what?
Don't worry about going to the wholesaler.
We're going to grind these beans for you.
Put them in a really cool bag,
will even design that bag to look really
cool, get it on grocery stores near you,
and for that you will pay a
premium compared to the commodity,
but hey,
it's closer to you grocery stores
or Bodegas and it's pretty,
it'll look good in your shelf.
It's already ground.
You don't have to worry about grinding it.
Third Category,
that head was this service where
a company would say, you know,
don't even worry about
going to the grocery store.
Come on into this space that we've
set aside. Let's call it a restaurant.
And if you want a cup of coffee, you
just tell us. We will go into the back,
grab our product, made up of
commodity, make you a cup of coffee,
bringing out to you,
and we will even clean the dish.
And for that you will pay a
premium compared to the product.
The point of their book was that
there was a fourth layer that they had
identified and they had been brought to
there that it had been brought to their
attention by Starbucks.
So logo time,
okay,
Starbucks was a service,
but how were they getting away with
charging as much as they were for a cup of
coffee? And they said it was
because of the experience, right?
You're just not going into a
diner and there's a ton of stuff.
You're going into a coffee experience
where they have lots of wood,
gorgeous wood paneling and lights and a
cool music playing and they abused the
Italian language in order
to sell you this stuff. Um,
and for that you consumers,
it's pretty much been shown
in the marketplace that are
willing to pay a premium
for that deep experience.
The reason I spent a little bit of time
with this model is to show that I think
there's another layer of
value that agency unlocks.
All of these require
attention to extract value.
It's either me with a scoop
me in a grocery store,
me and a diner or me at Starbucks,
but in the case of the room,
but I get value out of that object
when I'm at work. My cat is fed,
what am I am traveling?
There is value there.
That doesn't depend on the
16 hours of my attention,
which is limited and a very
competitive competitive space, right?
If you think about that,
the opportunity for value that you can
provide your users, your customers,
however you want to think about
them is comparatively infinite.
So I believe there's a post attention
value that we can begin to capitalize on
when we equip our products for this mode.
Number four,
PW singer wrote a scary book called uh,
something of war. I
have lost it, but ended.
He makes this argument that there
are certain technologies that once a
civilization adopts that can't go back.
He's thinking specifically
of drones in warfare.
Once we send machines to do the
fighting against other machines.
Why on earth would you send
your flesh and blood dark,
good conversation worth having.
But in terms of agent of technology,
I believe it's threshold. Once you
have the room, but in your life,
how much are you going to
want to go back to the Dyson?
Once you have a car that will drive you
and your kid to their school and you'd
get all this quality time with them,
how much are you going to want
to get behind the wheel and say,
get in the back and I really can't
talk to you. We get there, right?
The amount of value that you get from
an agent of technology is so great.
I believe that going back becomes
drudgery and for that it's a threshold
technology and for that reason it's a
massive competitive advantage to those
companies that adopted first.
Last bit.
It's Ai,
which I don't think it's the AI to fear,
but it's certainly interesting to me.
So let me take just a
moment and situate it.
I include this as part of the talk
because I don't know how well you guys are
versed in AI, but I may be
overstepping you baby, uh,
much more knowledgeable about this
than I am. Bear with me if you are,
but in the literature of Ai,
AI as a field is broken up into three
primary categories depending on the
capabilities of the AI itself.
The first one that,
the one that most people think of
when they hear AI is general AI,
so called because the AI can generalize
knowledge just like you or I can.
Uh, I run a blog about
science fiction interfaces,
super nerdy.
Um,
and so I'm going to make a couple of
Scifi references and this is my first who
does not know the movie war games.
Okay,
spoiler alert. I'm going to tell you a
little bit about war games, but in this,
there is an AI that has been trained
to play games and a lot of them are
harmless games, but one of them
is global thermonuclear war.
What the Ai doesn't know is that it's
actually tied into the nuclear arsenal of
the United States. Oh my God.
And it's got this countdown.
It's going to start playing this game
and ruined all our lives with the
protagonist ends up getting an idea
and you have the end of the film, Hey,
let's play tic TAC toe and it begins
to play tic tac toe with this AI called
whopper.
Terrible name.
Or Joshua a is the nickname and over
playing tic tac toe over and over again,
the Ai goes suddenly realizes, oh
hey, this is a game that can't be one.
And then it generalizes that
knowledge and thinks, Huh?
And it begins to run through scenarios
of global thermonuclear war and says, oh,
that's a game that cannot be won.
Why on Earth would we play it?
The countdown timer stops. They have
saved, guy gets the girl movie over,
but it's a pretty good
example of General Ai, right?
That AI is able to generalize doing what
you and I have done since toddler hood
when we took the physical things in the
abstractions in the world and then began
to build them to the adult knowledges
that we move through the world with today.
Once we have a general AI, one of the
first things that we're going to do,
whoever gets that,
it's going to ask it to say,
can you make a copy of yourself that
is a better predictor and has better
outcomes and make sure that copy is deeply
interested in making a copy of itself.
And that'll make a copy and that'll make
a copy and that will make a copy and
eventually what will come out the other
end. And it depends on who you ask,
how long that takes.
It could take a couple of hours,
it could take a couple of months,
but we'll be something so smart
that the running metaphor is,
it's intelligence will be
to us as ours is to a birds.
We will not have the language to think
in the questions it is interested in.
If you want to be scared of an AI,
be scared of that AI because if that
is not pre loaded with a care for human
wellness, we're in trouble. And in fact,
the mathematician and science fixture
fiction author Verner Venga probably
murdering the pronunciation coined to
this moment as we pass from general AI to
super AI is the singularity because
we don't know what life is like with a
functioning God able to
answer our questions.
Okay.
I raise these because agent of tech
is a mode of interaction that does not
involve these two.
It might set it up,
but let's talk about that
at the end of the talk.
The one that we have in the world now,
which is not as terrifying as these guys,
isn't narrow artificial intelligence,
so called because it's very good at one
or two things and can't generalize that
knowledge. I can't ask the Roomba to
help me plan a Thanksgiving dinner.
Not yet shirts and the roadmap,
but narrow AI is the one,
I'm a very practical person and this
is the one I'm most interested in.
Lots of exciting stuff to talk about here.
What do we do with all the jobs
that are going to be lost? Um, what,
what did we do? Who's got the last jobs?
I think it's designers and judges. Um,
but let's talk about this because this
is what we have in the world now for my
money. We talk a lot about AI
in terms of what it can do,
but I'm most interested in
what the relationship is of
the user to the work that
the AI is doing.
And I found three categories.
I may be wrong if so,
let's chat about it.
But the first one is automatic stuff
that should just happen, right? Uh,
a pacemaker is a good example. I never
want a pacemaker to ask me in the morning,
do you want me to make your pace?
Because the answer is always yes.
Same thing with the grocery
store. Automatic door. I
never want that to ask, right?
Just open,
just do it.
This sort of thing does fit
narrow artificial intelligence,
but only for well constrained
unpersonalized things.
Assistance are things that you
would use to help you do a task,
right? Like an angel on your
shoulder, whispering in your ear.
Scifi referenced number two,
like Jarvis for iron man or now Friday,
right?
It's an assistant to him though I make
the case in the blog that Jarvis is the
iron man. Um, and when I thought
about this, I was like, well,
what do we parse as it,
what do we give to the assistance of the
world and never want to hand off to a
non human? And I found four and a half
categories and they're listed up there.
The first one is our jobs.
If you and I have an economic
agreement that I will do work for you,
and instead I handed that to an
AI and spend my days on the beach,
we'd probably an ethical problem. There's
an argument to be made of, Oh hey,
why don't you sell me that AI so
that I can use it at my company?
But for the most part,
you're not doing your job.
You're sneaking away from your job.
So jobs are something that we want
humans to be outfitted with assistance,
not agents.
The second is human connection.
I suspect that in about 10 years I'm going
to greatly prefer an AI for my doctor
to be able to recognize and diagnose
the problems that I have with my health.
Right.
Already we know that Watson can read every
medical publication that is published
around the world, pretty much
in real time. It's diagnosis.
Despite the MD Anderson troubles of late,
I'm going to become much more
confident in than a humans.
That is not true for a nurse. Part of the
purpose of the nurses human connection.
I don't want an AI waking me up and
saying, do you need more painkiller?
That's not going to help me feel cared
for. Helped me feel loved not left.
It's not going to get me
on the road to wellness.
So if human connection is part of the
purpose of the thing that I don't think we
ever want to hand that off to an agent
and we do want it to be an assistant
the last year related, right.
If the point is physiology,
then I can't send a robot to do the work.
Right?
I can't send a robot to go
to the gym for me. I'd be,
I'd be jacked if I could. Skills are
similar. If I'm trying to learn French,
I can't certain send an agent to French
class in order to study the language for
me, I have to be there so that
my brain acquires those skills.
Lastly, there's a half
category of art. Um,
I say it's a half category because there
are plenty of examples where a computer
generated stuff we find
delightful until Arius,
this is inspire robot popular of late,
but it's a neural net that's trying to
create inspirational images and they're
just hilarious.
But the reason I say it's still
a half category is because, uh,
when people find out that a poem
they love has been written by an AI,
they feel betrayed.
Not True with visual imagery.
So it's a half category and I'm sure
they're going to be artists who are going
to rock out using AI in their work.
But that leaves agent of tech,
right?
That thing where we partner with a piece
of technology in order to do the things
for us that we want it to do.
And that means everything else.
If it's not one of those
four and a half categories,
that's a lot.
That includes like things
that we're not good at,
right?
The whole reason we had autopilot is
that humans have only about 20 minutes
worth of vigilance. And I know you're
already past that in the audience,
so thank you.
Um,
but where we can only pay attention
to a signal for 20 minutes before our
attention begins to drift.
Um,
and so we need partners to help us
with the tasks that we must do that are
longer,
that are beyond common human capabilities.
It includes technologies
that were unwilling to do.
We've known about the Pacific gyres
for the better part of two decades now.
We haven't been cleaning them and yes,
we could probably put some humans and
some boats to go out and clean that mess
up. Um, but once we have robots doing,
I think we're going to be hard pressed
to find humans that want to take those
robots place. By the way, the Pacific
guard does not look like that. Just soupy,
plastic mess. It's not actual
trash floating in the ocean.
And it also includes stuff that
we just cannot do alone. Right?
We know we only have about 4
billion years in this planet,
which doesn't seem like a
lot, but boy, howdy getting
a, an entire civilization. Um,
to some of the rock is a major undertaking
and we can send humans out into the
void,
but we're fragile.
Error prone sending robots
is a much saner idea,
but the farther away from us they get,
the longer that communication time is.
And we have to have some kind of smart
on those robots as they explore the
galaxy to handle things that happen in
between the moment of communication.
Fortunately,
NASA is already on this.
They have something called the
NASA agent architecture for right.
But we can't do this task alone that we
have to do and we're going to have to
partner very in very smart ways with our
technology in order to make it happen.
Which brings us back to Ada.
You'll remember that eight is objection
or the Lovelace objection is touring
call.
That was Ken computers take initiative
and I think I've certainly shown that.
Oh yes. The patterns that he showed
at the beginning where they can, um,
even the examples that I showed
show that they do already,
a few people have already started to
move their technology in this direction.
I'm writing for both business
reasons and for ethical reasons.
I think that they should in certain cases.
Yeah.
So part of the mission I've gotten writing
this book and going and making talks
like this is to convince people that,
hey, let's move in this direction.
Let's build our products such
they're equipped this way.
And so I'm going to leave you with three
questions to ask for the products that
you guys build.
And the first is basic in that it works
from the micro interaction level all the
way up to the strategic
directions of products and to say,
are we asking users to do something that
we could do for them if they so wanted.
Once you answer that question and you
begin to create the agency of your
products or agent of modes of your
products, then you have to say, okay,
well it just not purely agent IV.
The rooms in the world I think
are going to be the exception.
Something that just fits nicely
into one of those categories.
How can our product support automation
when the confidence is super high agent
tive when it's a task that the user
doesn't want to do and assist of modes
because smart products products
we'll have to work in all three.
And lastly,
how does our product help the
user, right? Whether the product,
the Ai is taking initiative or
the human is taking initiative,
how do we flow smoothly
between those modes?
I think once we answer those
questions, we will be, uh,
many further steps on the way to getting
our technology to take advantage of
this conceptual framework
of agent TIF technologies.
Um,
so you can follow me at agent tiff
tech or Chris Nossel but that's it.
Let's have a chat about it.
Um,
so I had a question about where the
initiative of decision making falls into
this pyramid. So you mentioned a
lot of tasks that, uh, agentic IV,
uh, technology will do
what we're unwilling to do.
But it sounded like that's where the
humans have to kind of give the initiative
to these other devices to do.
How do we kind of,
it's like how do we seamlessly
move into a place where humans,
where we can suggest things that we
think should be done and humans will,
um, trust that suggestion. Right?
I think that's a big problem that we
have now as we move into a world where
things are getting more
and more intelligent. Yup.
And people can kind of get scared of those
suggestions, which might sound simple,
but they don't know all of the
algorithms that are going on behind it.
And so that it's moving in that
direction. Do you have any, yeah.
And in fact, earlier this year,
the EU passed a resolution, um,
about AI that included a provision
called the right to explanation,
which says that if you are subject
to an [inaudible] decision,
you as a citizen have the right to
understand how that decision was made,
which is going to be problematic in
the world of neural nets. But, um,
in the book I describe a pattern called
a hood to look under and it's a trust
building pattern. And the notion is
that for any decision you should be,
and it's easier with narrow AI,
you should give that user an opportunity
to open up the hood and see how that
decision was made,
disagree with that decision,
and either provide categorical
imperatives for future behavior,
white lists, black lists, inclusions,
or even particular tweaks.
So I think you should be able to go
down all the way, um, in common usage.
I suspect that's going to be similar to
the get narrative camera. Wait a minute.
Why did you show me that
image? Oh yeah, you're right.
That's the only image from
the party that was clear.
And the chode the people. Well and the
balance was right. Okay, I agree with you.
And over time, having that hood to
look under will help me build trust.
And when I don't trust it
and it's got it wrong to be,
to influence it such that it
behaves the way I want it to.
So check out that pattern in the book.
And I think it may answer your question.
Um,
there was a second question implied there,
which is about recommendations and I
think that any system should be able to
recommend to users new behaviors.
Um,
occasionally there's a,
there's an ugly tension between agency
that goes off and does its work out of
your attention and the brand importance
of not becoming a commodity. Right?
Brands want to be first and foremost.
Um,
so there's a weird tension there and I
believe that the corporate pressure we
will have will be to over communicate
and our job as designers is to match what
the humans want.
Um,
but I don't have any problem with an
agent coming and making an occasional
recommendation to me as a, as a user.
And I suspect users at large. Um,
so I don't think the
decision itself is a problem.
Understanding how it was made and then
being able to tweak that as the important
part of the pattern.
Why designers and judges,
why are they the last one set of jobs?
Uh, yes, I suspect it's because
that we do the same thing,
right?
We judge what's good and we know how to,
we are good at understanding humans
and then designing systems, uh,
depending on your definition of design
that optimized for a human set of effects,
um, and Ai's will not know that
inherently from the very beginning. Um,
and they'll come to us to
ask those questions. Um,
similarly I think that a AI's are an
alien and tele or the generally I will be
an alien intelligence and they'll need
to turn to judges to know in order to
understand what to do or what humans
would ordinarily do in the edge cases.
I'm in law as of course, all
about the edge cases. Um,
so I think those are the reasons.
The last two,
I didn't say this over
the course of the talk,
but I'm actually pretty hopeful about
the role that agent of technologies would
have in setting up a
general AI to be benign.
I know it's tricky to
say, but, um, if the,
if the output of a ton of agent of
technologies in the world is a set of
instructions for how you want things
to behave in order to serve you well,
what we'll have at the end of that,
at the advent of general AI
is 4 million laws of robotics,
right?
Where an AI,
we can read all of these instructions
at lunch can begin to infer, oh,
this is how humans generally
want to be treated.
And that's a pretty important big data
piece of information to handle general AI.
So I'm hopeful in that regard. Yes. Uh,
thinking through this,
but what are some examples of agent of
products that you've found have been able
to close the gap?
Maybe between the manual traditional way
of doing something and then handing off
that service and uh,
building off that maybe some Asian two
products were completely AI generated
products.
Like the poems that you've found people
just did not like she didn't having
generated.
How,
how have you seen ways that that gap can
be closed to where they do appreciate
those poems in the future,
for instance?
Um, so let's tackle the two. Uh,
the first question was what are some
examples of products that have genuinely
managed to work fine and go from
human distrust to human trust?
Spam filters?
Spam filters are really great example,
partially because when
they were first there,
people don't necessarily trust them.
Um,
partially because well done spam
filters and include Jimmy on this,
I'm still give you the opportunity
to go in and review, open the hood.
Do I agree with you on these things?
They give controls for blacklists.
I never want to hear from this
person again. And white lists.
I always wanted to hear from this person,
um, and incorporates deep, uh, uh,
narrow artificial intelligences in
order to end and a group feedback.
If you know 20 people all mark,
this is undesirable.
You can pretty much guarantee you that
the other users that are similar to them,
we'll find the same thing. So, uh, email
filters are a great, great example.
Uh, and partially because
like, I dunno about you,
but I haven't gone into my rejected folder
in a really long time because I trust
them. Yeah. Does anyone
still go in? Right.
So that's a great example as a model.
The second part of your question
was, oh, a things that have failed.
I don't have a great, uh, answer for
that right off the top of my head.
The get narrative is a risky example,
partially because that
company has been struggling,
but I don't think it's because
of the agency of the product.
I think it's actually because of
our concerns about privacy, um,
that the domains in which I can wear a
camera and not worry about the privacy of
the people in front of me. It's
actually pretty limited to cross my day.
It's not my work.
Certainly not my inside my family unless
I'm just sharing those to a small group.
Um, like maybe a party, but still when I
wore one and I did for about four months,
people would be like, oh,
what's that? Maybe hiking,
maybe public things like
walking around the city. Um,
but that's a small percentage of
certainly my time in the world.
So I think that the problems that
they had weren't about the technology,
but about bringing that technology
to that particular domain.
I'll think about it a little more.
Um,
I think Roomba is making a big mistake
with the announcement that they gave this
week that they have slowly been
building up a model of people's homes.
And even though they said we'll let users
opt in to sharing that home platform
and the details that Roomba has
found with a co marketers, um,
it's still super creepy knowing that it's
creating a model of your home that can
be hacked by anyone.
So I don't know how that's going to fair.
I suspect that the announcement this week
was a bit of a flag to see how people
responded and I, it's being overshadowed,
overshadowed by modern politics,
but I hope that they get,
um,
some negative feedback because people
are going to be creeped out. Um,
I can think of some other I examples, um,
and tweet them out there if you'd like.
I will volunteer. Three of the
things, uh, for the things,
the first is one of the questions that
I get asked a lot about is what do we do
with the humans in the world of, and
I, I don't have a pat answer for that,
but I am a big believer in universal
basic income. Um, I think it's the,
we have always had technologies
that slowly obviate jobs,
but the speed at which we are
going to replace entire fields,
it's going to be massive and we have
to come at that from a cultural answer,
not a, uh, not a, Oh, it'll work
itself out. Free market kind of answer.
The other three are sort of the next
steps over the course of this book,
and I'll give this to you guys because
you're pretty advanced audience.
I talk about the world as if
there were one user and one agent.
That's certainly not true.
We have to get good at that foundation,
but over time it's going to be user one
user to many agents and even multiple
users to multiple agents.
I don't talk about that here,
but it's something that we're going to
have to solve as a community of practice
working with this. Uh, the second
thing is that I didn't talk,
I don't talk about the third category,
the assistive tech.
I believe that the long history we have
of interaction design will fit us well
to assist of technology,
but I'm also quite concerned that that
becomes a human crutch for cognition as
opposed to equipment that makes us better.
I don't also talk about the flow between
agented and a system and automatic and
this book,
but it is something that if you begin
to incorporate agent of aspects of your
product,
and it's not purely agent of like the
Roomba that you have to work through.
And I don't give any advice to that. I'm
working like with Vic and shines ladder.
Right? Let's get this done first and
then we can build up those other skills.
Thank you guys.